hallo hier ist wieder eure mal wanne und
willkommen bei anne will zu essen
bekommt lena ich habe im internet
gesehen dass es die unterschiedlichsten
abo boxen oder dachte ich okay wer
sollte das besser ausprobieren als
vermesser und dann habe ich ein paar
seiten da angeschrieben und hab gesagt
und ich würde gerne an boxen und
unternahmen voll viele den lago klar
machen wir krieg krieg dazu geschenkt ja
und da ist ein bisschen viel geworden
sind mache ich ein paar teile heute habe
ich fünf box dreimal beauty und noch
zwei andere guck mal wie gesund ich bin
nicht trinkt so zitrone ingwer tee aber
irgendwie schmeckt das bitter ich glaube
die zitronenschale ist nicht so ins hat
die erste box ist die glossybox die
schon so vom hörensagen gehört habe
beim testen für mich schon richtig wie
so ein beauty box also einmal ein
magazin was ist wohl von denen gibt es
ist meine mutter eine probe für ein
bruder was wirklich wehtun ing
thun konnte wird noch gar nicht welche
farbe ich weiß ich ganz genau was es ist
nicht gut
weißer nagellack find ich cool
wimperntusche aber es sind dies alles
nur so produktion und einen nagellack
also die box kostet je nach dem 250 bis
15 euro pro monat dafür muss ich sagen
hätte ich mehr erwartet als es ist ganz
nett aber
aber nette karte ich glaube ich freue
mich darüber meisten unser nächste box
ist eine t box ja du kannst dir auch tee
monatlich zuschicken lassen hätte ich
nicht gedacht
die ist von kappa box heißt dass die
links alle in die infobox
es gibt immer noch eine schöne
verpackung da wenn ich jetzt sehr
gespannt schoko chili kräuter gewürze
geil stracciatella tee schmeckt nach
stracciatella eis handset mit einer
zitrone preiselbeer minute und
granatapfel hin der mit ganz viel drin
also noch ein buch steht räume stehen
früchtetee und steht sogar ganz wichtig
denn ich bin ja diese box für mich schön
der tk setzt 999 im monat und das finde
ich ok weil das kann sie jederzeit
kündigen und ja also auf diese box bin
ich super gespannt denn die ist einfach
mal riesig das ist die neue installer
scheinlich einfach ganz die
luftpolsterfolie drin eine tasche ist
was haben wir hier eine chance
theresia fashion geil was haben wir hier
wisst ihr was das ist also lustige
geschichte
das ist dieses zeug was die wimpern
länger werden lässt aber durch meinen
grünen star habe ich das quasi in
tropfenform also ich muss mir das jeden
abend in die augentropfen das ist die
medikamenten die muss und die haben halt
gleiche wirkung deswegen habe ich halt
schon so lange wimpern und jetzt kriege
ich das
extra das jetzt auch benutzen würden
häufig als das swiss made soll ich dir
die fingernägel schneiden glitzersteine
unserem sec geschehen aber warum bekomme
ich glück warsteiner schweizer
schokolade gaddafi hat ein haarspray
habe ich ein geschenk für meine freundin
das ist nämlich ein riesenbock sie in
style box war damals es gibt zwei
maschine gibt auch die mainz es ist eine
box aus der schweiz
da fühle ich mich dem buch ihn ja fast
ganz nah weißweinen dahin und einen bus
aus der schweiz
also wenn man sie zum beispiel drei
monate bestellt kostet 79 euro kostet
die tore boxer aber wenn sie gleichen
können er kann wie es halt live ohne
dass uns war das beauty jetzt wieder
beiseite legen und lud jetzt
ausprobieren das ist die lose boxen hier
eine kürzen hülle von marvel abdecken
gerade what the [ __ ] und shit land ist
das kissenbezug und kissen
da mag es von der hobbit wenn das ein
gandalf lesezeichen ein stück ist von
nestlé
eigentlich mag ich an diesem tag
vereinigt alle gemeinsamen breaking
badesalz exklusiv luchies deshalb gibt
es jetzt gemacht da ist wohl jemand ganz
schlau gewesen
ein stück von einem film drin aber ich
habe keine ahnung
eine box kostet 25 euro 3 überhaupt den
kosten 23 und ein 16 monats abo sind 20
euro pro monat verlieren sie ist fertig
zum mädchen unter letzte tipps für oder
gar nichts drin
mein basteln herz sagt ja wieder
behalten und wassel damit war stimmt die
stereo box das fand ich gut die haben
naturkosmetik und halt alles sehr fair
das kommt aus einem land osterei und es
ist vegan kurier zum abschminken
da habe ich es echt ist gab es gebraucht
das riecht nach le monde nova lipstick
dass das alles so fair und bio und vegan
und das ist eine verführerische
gesichtsmuskel mit mint schokolade und
honig sie richtig gut aber gut also
natürlich geht's weiter geht's weiter
geht's intensiver haarkur
das sind wir schon große packungen das
sind hier richtige richtige packung und
das letzte sehr natürliche kosmetik da
ist auch was mit beauty dabei aber die
pflegeprodukte bin ich sehr gespannt
wenn das so gut ist kostet meine damen
und herren gab es eine box verschenken
und kannst dir eine box kaufen und du
kannst ein abo machen
für 19 90 monatlich und dann halt ein
paar monate ist wirklich ein guter preis
also kriegs ja wirklich gute
naturprodukte da muss man ja auch mal zu
sagen ohne tiefere krone den ganzen
scheiß das ist kostet hatten sie mehr
aber letzte box kinder vertrag nicht das
war nur der erste teil denn ich wusste
nicht dass es so viele leute zu sagen
werden eine box zu schicken und ich
danke an andere firmen die das machen
und mir eine box schicken ich habe kein
geld dafür bekommen dass ich das jetzt
gezeigt habe ich dachte mir einfach nur
es gibt so viele boxen so viele abos und
sonst aus abos dass es perfekt